hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein kleines grundrezept
und zwar werde ich eine französische
buttercreme herstellen jetzt denken sich
wahrscheinlich viele buttercreme das mag
ich nicht so gerne aber die französische
buttercreme ist wirklich total
variationsreich und geschmacklich auch
sehr toll man kann sie vor allem auch
unter fondant orten streichen ohne dass
ich davon dann auflöst das heißt es wird
eine ideale alternative zum beispiel zu
einer kanal bei dieser buttercreme ist
es besondere sie besteht aus butter und
eiern die vorher erhitzt werden das
heißt ihr habt auch kein rohes ei weiß
mit drin
und ihr könnt später eine frucht
buttercreme draus machen eine schoko
buttercreme eine nuss buttercreme oder
eben was ganz anderes
ich zeige euch jetzt hier einmal das
grundrezept und zeigt euch später im
video wie ihr sehen variieren können für
die buttercreme brauche ich 225 g weiche
butter 3 eier das sind jetzt etwa 165
gramm eine prise salz und 105 gramm
zucker jetzt nämlich zuerst einmal die
eier und gebt sie jetzt entweder in
einer küchenmaschine mit hitze funktion
so mache ich das jetzt ohne
küchenmaschine funktioniert das ganze so
dass erst die eier gemeinsam mit dem
zucker und dem salz in eine schüssel
gibt und dies ist auf dem wasserbad
stellt das heißt unten im topf habt ihr
viel wasser das wird aufgekocht und darf
auch die ganze zeit über kochen und dort
wird die eier zucker mischung dann
während ruhe während dem rühren so etwa
fünf minuten erhitzt und sie erreicht so
85 grad
falls ihr aber eine küchenmaschine habt
könnt jetzt ganz auch in der
küchenmaschine machen und ein bisschen
einfacher gestalten und geht jetzt hier
eier zucker und salz rein
jetzt wird das ganze auf 85 grad erhitzt
und die temperatur solltet ihr dann so
etwa fünf minuten halten
nach von piloten kann ich jetzt die
temperatur wegnehmen und beim rühren
müsst ihr auf jeden fall darauf achten
dass die eier nicht gewinnen das heißt
lieber auf stufe drei bis vier und nicht
zu niedrig und im wasserbad so riße
jetzt die schüssel mit den eiern von
barwasser bad hair unternehmen mit mit
dem handrührgerät oder einer
küchenmaschine die eier kahlschlag
das dauerte etwa 20 bis 25 minuten und
in der zeit wird die eier masse sehr
stabil und fest
und ich kann dann so etwa in zehn
minuten schon mal die butter nehmen und
auch weiß schaumig schlagen
die eier mache ist jetzt kalt
aufgeschlagen sehr guter etwa 26 grad
angenommen und sieht jetzt so aus also
die konsistenz ist auch wirklich sehr
dickflüssig und fest und inzwischen habe
ich jetzt auch schon mal die butter
aufgeschlagen und es war am anfang ist
jetzt ziemlich gelb und wenn man dann
wirklich lange genug rührt fünf bis zehn
minuten dann wird sie so richtig schön
weiß schaumig und das heißt erleben dass
man die butter maximal schaumig
aufgeschlagen hat die butter werde jetzt
unter die eier masse untergehoben und
das ist dann im prinzip die grund
buttercreme die man herstellen kann
ich finde die buttercreme jetzt mal um
um euch drei verschiedene buttercreme
varianten zu zeigen
könnt ihr entweder zum beispiel etwas
meinl extrakt nehmen und großzügig mit
dazu geben da habt ihr nämlich eine
wandelnde buttercreme oder ihr macht es
ganz verschiedene und zwar habe ich hier
ein bisschen geschmolzene
zartbitterschokolade die gebe ich jetzt
eine schälchen rein und daraus entsteht
dann eine schoko buttercreme
ins zweite schildchen gebe ich ein
bisschen hippie mit rein und zwar hatte
ich als tiefgefrorener himbeeren teppich
auftauen lassen und ein bisschen
eingekocht damit die flüssigkeit ein
bisschen verdunstet und die gebe ich
hiermit rein und habe eine himbeer
buttercreme und das könnt ihr natürlich
auch mit ganz verschiedenem obst macher
mit kirchen mit himbeer mit brombeeren
also mit eigentlich allem was ihr da
habt
und hier bei der letzten variante gebe
ich noch lernen curt mit dazu lemon
gehört ist ein brotaufstrich den ich
selber gemacht habe und dafür gibt es
auch schon ein rezept auf meinen kanal
und das gebe ich jetzt hier mit rein und
habe eine zitrone oder creme und im
prinzip könnt ihr jetzt auch zum
beispiel muss passen mit rein geben und
können so ein bisschen oder einem
angriff machen oder auch die buttercreme
mails linke aromatisieren und so ganz
verschiedene cremes herstellen und die
cremes sind wirklich super lecker
schmecken auch sehr leicht trotz dass
sie eine buttercreme sind und ich finde
ihr solltet ihr auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren und der creme eine chance
geben jedenfalls könnte die cremes super
als basis für vonlanthen nehmen wie ich
bereits schon gesagt habe und deswegen
finde ich sie wirklich hervorragend also
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen und auf meinem blog
gibts natürlich noch ganz viele weitere
ideen und rezepte
diese menge reicht es für eine kleine
torte mit 20 zentimetern durchmesser aus
oder zum beispiel auch als füllung für
eine große torte und alles weitere
findet ihr auf meinem blog und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis zum nächsten mal tschüss